all right so I'm Erica today I'll be
giving an introduction to Vector search
are we all familiar with Vector search
Vector databases no okay one that's fine
um hopefully after this talk you will
gain an understanding and understand
what Vector databases do and how you can
perform Vector search by yourself I am a
developer Advocate at web8 and open
source Vector database um you can run it
four different ways um either we be
embedded which runs natively in your
application so once you close it it
completely kills also Docker kubernetes
and then also we have our manag SAS
which is called WCS and you can get
started with a 14-day free sandbox which
is great to get started so you don't
have to put your credit card
down point of the clickers to not have
to go over there okay so today I'll be
covering what traditional search is um
and then I'll they'll like lead me into
what Vector search is and how it is
different um then I'll give an
introduction to we8 not to salesy just
so you can gauge an understanding of
what we8 is um the different directions
that we can head in for search and kind
of where we are now in the like
retrieval augmented generation with the
llm kind of space and then I'll share a
demo and then a python notebook so um we
have the we8 GitHub repository and I
created the we8 recipe so it's like
these uh really short notebooks that are
written in Python and is very user
friendly in my opinion so I guess if you
don't think so you can share your
feedback with
me all right so starting off with
traditional search for how do we uh does
anyone know how we typically find
information um kind of like what happens
in the back end of
Google that's
fine
so um yeah that is yeah that is another
thing as well um I guess it's build on
top of that um so you take your query
embedding so what is weate that is
transformed into an embedding so just a
vector of numbers and then you compare
that with each um each um embedding that
is stored in your database um so you
take the query and then you try to find
documents that are nearest to that query
embedding so the traditional approach
with this is keyword search so I hope we
have some wine lovers in here let's say
you're looking for some white wine you
know that you want it to be white a dry
medium full body and you want it to pair
very well with seafood because that's
what you're cooking tonight so you're
like okay I have an idea of what I want
it's a chardonay of what I'm looking for
maybe I'm just curious about what kind
of brand I want um so here you have
three options but what happens if you
are kind of a newbie with wine and you
just want to wine that pairs well with
seafood because you don't have wine for
seafood in your database or maybe Google
isn't familiar with wine for seafood
that doesn't make sense no products are
going to be found and this is the
limitation of traditional search engines
um so in order to find lines that pair
well with seafood maybe Google has a
list of synonyms that someone like a
search relevance engineer has put
together so um when you search for
seafood it knows Al maybe they want fish
or shellfish or saltwater fish and then
that can help you find your chardonay
that you're on the hunt
for all right so the limitations of
keyword search is the lack of
understanding of context the wine of
seafood I want a white wine I don't want
just like any other kind of wine I'm
like very specific so there's that lack
of understanding with keyword search um
then there's also the sensitivity to the
word variations what if you have a typo
you're screwed so that's not very good
um and then also it is limited to one
language so a lot of these ml models is
specifically with coher they are
multilingual you search in English you
can get objects back in add Japanese and
Spanish
Etc so that leads me on to Vector
search okay so now again I have my query
wine for seafood the vector search
engine is understanding my query
directly and it's saying okay you want
this sh because it pairs well with the
dinner that you're
making and how this is retrieved is
because your data has this wine and a
description about it and just briefly it
just knows that it's good with fish
notice how in the description it doesn't
have like that it's a wine or that it's
a seafood it knows that fish is seafood
so it's going to return this
object okay so now y Vector search I see
a lot of like oo ah it is very nice in
my
opinion um but yeah so bu Vector search
and I guess really kind of what this
slide covers is not why we but we is one
option we do have competitors um out
there but that's relevant um um but it
just allows you to store data objects
and Vector embeddings together um so it
stores the object along with its
embedding so you can do that dual search
and then um these embeddings are
generated from ml models and it just
allows you to seamlessly search through
even billions of objects um some people
come up to us and they're like I have
10,000 objects can I store it in weaving
it's like yeah we pushed like 900
million objects into a database and it
is fully functional and it's able to
return the objects at a seamless Pace um
so one thing that I like about this
visual on the right hand side is this is
a vector space um so you have your
unstructured data whether that be text
images audio you can also store the
structured data as well if you have that
um and that is converted into the an a
vector we doesn't handle that um you can
use um models from open AI cohere
hugging face Etc
any bottle um that does this and maybe
it just just handles the orchestration
of that um so you pass in your open AI
key your coher key and then V will
transform your data into vectors and
then it will store it in this beautiful
Vector space um this is just a simple uh
graph just for visualization purposes
obviously with real world data it's a
bit more messy um but notice how here we
have animals on the left hand side and
then fruits on the right this is
dependent on the embedding that is
generated from the data right um so on
the left we have query kitten um just
similar to the wine example I don't have
kitten in my database but um the ml
model understands that kitten is a cat
just a young cat um and then also you
can see that with respect to the vector
space dog is far far away from banana
because they are not
similar okay so again how does this work
you take the data you pass it to this ml
model to generate the embedding which is
just a
long and then how does it work so you
have the ml model and it creates this
Vector space and this is an index for
making quick and efficient
search then you plug in your data see my
example of wine so my data are the pink
dots and notice how it is where where
the fish is where the beer and wine and
not really both fruit I mean I guess you
could cook dinner with fruit but I don't
know um that is just the example so your
data is plotted in the vector
space and then you're running the query
so now it's honing into this one
particular spot in the vector space and
then it's able to retrieve all of the
options in the circle so you're looking
for the Chardonnay but it's going to
give other ones that are maybe pretty
similar so you have like a sanon block
in there and notice how it's like maybe
the taste the notes are different do we
have wine connoisseurs in here I love
wine personally but
um self on BL it's like it's a white
line pretty similar to shub name even
not as buttery but pretty similar so
even if that's returned the objects
aren't going to be
bad so then to put it no worries so then
to put it all together we have theor
space you add your own data then you
have your search for and output you get
the result and this is done extremely
fast and I'll jump into how that is
done so an introduction to
weate so weate has a custom
implementation of hnsw written and go so
this allows for efficient and quick
similarity search um so Vector databases
use approximate nearest neighbor
algorithms in order to do this kind of
quick retrieval rather than doing like a
brute force method where you take the
query embedding and then compare it to
each object in your database cuz imagine
how long that would take if you have
millions of objects yes I always meant
to ask so is this an algorith that is
older before embeddings came about or
it's actually an ending Al is this hnsw
do you guys St think is fairly new Conor
is actually research sence 2016 so U
yeah they they
um I mean the F the F stuff that we were
talking about earlier that's a little
earlier than that
201 so fairly new um even I spoke with
him about it but like mongod d they're
not Factor database native but they are
adding this functionality because they
do see the importance of it um what does
h s swed stand for nsw yeah um
hierarchical navigable small world I
never fully write it out because if I
have to say it I'm gonna fumble so say
H&S W is this a new algorithm uh from
2016 yeah it's like fairly recent I feel
like in I know from a nips event for
image similarity to find copyright
infringement like YouTube or videos
that's active area for search and their
new algorithms coming out that they're
probably more recent than this but for
images
only I mean yeah because my example was
only about text but we can also hand out
images audio and we have like a multi
I'm get to Carri it away but you can
also search with images and videos and
this doesn't need any Keys it runs on
the CPU it doesn't need GPU is that
right CPU yes yeah and then depending on
if you it locally then you might need
like a powerful machine or you can let
us handle it with our we cloud service
but deping if you have a powerful
computer then go for
it yeah um so quickly what this is it's
not extremely important to the talk um
but just quickly covering what hsw is so
it creates this hierarchal graph so it
has the three layers the top layer
includes the query and then layer zero
on the bottom contains all of the data
um so the blue dot the the goal is to
find the document that is nearest to
this query Vector right so we're going
to go all the way down Traverse the
graph downwards and then the blue dot
will the pink dot will be returned from
the blue
qu I promise to get started with W8 you
do not touch this at all you can
configure hnsw but uh you don't have
to okay so then uh recently we released
hnsw and product quantization together
and what this does is it compresses the
vectors so it's great for saving memory
I believe it's a bit slower because you
you're going to have that trade-off but
um it is more cost efficient and for
some people it's like you have to bounce
a trade-off for your application it's
slower with the Quant a bit slower um
because you're compressing it and then
it you saves meory but um Conor can you
explain more if you have on query or is
you doing that um you usually um it was
kind of confounded by two things a lot
of times you would bring it back to the
original representation to like Resort
the queue and then also um we like do it
for uh dis and memory optimization so is
is kind of confounded by it's not like
product quantization itself is slower
that's like what you were talking about
with the nerves competition where they
hash the vectors basically with
quantization but it's like moving it
from dis to memory is is also kind of
why thises
this so then we have like the
neighborhoods is what they call it and
the dot is going to represent that area
um so it's
like bit slower but it is compressing
it all right um so we also is has like a
modular ecosystem and this is really
what differentiates us from our
competitors um so we have the we have we
clients so you can write this in Python
JavaScript typescript Etc
um but then if you have your own vectors
you can just bring your vectors to weate
and then store it in your instance which
is awesome because I don't know you
already have your embeddings it's like
why run it again um so that's something
that is awesome and then with indexing
we have HS wpq um but then with search
um so we have bm25 which is keyword
search and then we have semantic search
which is Vector search so wine for
seafood and then we have hybrid which is
bm25 and semantic matched together which
is really good because some people will
say I have this
longit they have data that is maybe not
correctly represented in these
embeddings um so the key to that is the
model just doesn't completely understand
what your data is so what hybrid is
doing is using bm25 and semantic
together and the weighting of it is
dependent on the alpha parameter um so
if you set Alpha to 0.5 it's weighting
it both equally yeah so it's the first
time I see about indexing your database
um I mean I know what classic databases
indexing is useful but how does it work
what's the purpose of indexing here for
your use case um so it's properly
storing your data um so like the vector
space and a few like a here I just so
this um so this is indexing like the
properly storing your data of like okay
this side has beer wine fish and then
the other side has fruit or something
it's just like that indexing is very
important for proper search
yeah um and then for the results you can
improve it so we have a question and
answering which is like um what is weate
it will output the answer um then you
also have the generative module which is
using rag which I'll cover and it's like
extremely exciting these days um and
then we have reranking um so we use
coheres model C reranking so once you
retrieve your objects and it's like eh
the results aren't great let's rank the
results so you're comparing the query to
the um out the objects that came out of
that answer and then ranking it again so
basing that query off of each objects
and then maybe the fifth um answer
previously is now the first one because
it is the most relevant um and that is a
bit slower but if um accuracy is key for
you that that's very important
okay so emerging directions and search
so I guess I covered it previously but I
wanted to cover hybrid search being a
new thing that we added to we8 and we
also have our hybrid Fusion so I love
this image I give it to our design
woman's spit Lana and I said I want a
fire and then dense and sparse
embeddings to make it hybrid so uh dense
is Vector search and then sparse is just
like that bm25 like z00 Z1 like a whole
bunch of zeros right and then D is the
vector search where each position has a
meaning okay but now moving on to like
the hot new topic of retrieval augmented
generation so we've all used CH GPT I
won't tell your
employer but if you ask chat DPT what is
the weather today it's gonna say I have
no clue my cut off date was September or
just said September 2021 it's like well
you're useless to me because you're not
up to date or maybe you have a question
on like documentation that you're trying
to like build an app on and it's like
stream I've never heard of it well
actually it does know about streamline
but like maybe not their latest
features so the solution to this is
connecting the llm to a vector database
so here we have I'll start with step one
so you have your documents and then you
have your weate database and you have
your prompt um so you're taking the
filtered relevant documents from your
query passing that on to the chat GPT
API um not
really um including with coher as well
but our generative module we do support
open Ai and there are various models I
think like two or three models and then
also coh here as well so we're taking
those uh relevant documents passing it
on to chat GPT so it has that knowledge
of what the weather is today or what is
the newest feature in Streamlight and
then it is going to customize that
response so that's really taking it from
step one to step two and it's able to
basically like chat with your PDFs chat
with your PowerPoint documents there's
like a whole bunch of ETL companies like
unstructured new AI Vector flow Etc that
have the that give you the option to
take your PDF documents convert that
into embeddings and then now you get to
chat with it which is really
awesome how do you pass it to the
openingi is it just the document itself
so like if it's like a massive document
it just won't yeah well I mean you have
chunk it yes chunk uh trunking is key
especially for the long documents um
because there is like the rate limit
that you'll hit with opening eyes so it
can't be extremely long but some of
their models do support longer context
windows I think like open has like a 16k
um but some are fairly smaller so
trunking is key um and I would say yeah
you'd have to do that beforehand but
like llama index supports that right
before you're going to factorize your
data you can specify the token limit and
then also another thing is like the
rolling window so um when you hit the
trunk and it ends here you're going to
want to have that overlapping window so
it has that knowledge of the past
paragraph which can then improve the
results but it's like bit staying
focused demo time I want to
share what we built at we
oh no will this go
away we go okay so this is verba the
golden
Rag and it's powered by we8 and what
this is is if you ask a question what is
weate chat gbt would have no clue but if
you ask verba it will point you to
exactly where it specifies what weate is
so it's citing its source but then it's
also generating the out in the
background um so this is a cast result
my colleague Edward is extremely
talented and put this together um so we
also have caching in the background so I
think at some point we might hit all of
the questions someone could
ask so he won't get charged anymore um
but you can see that it says like weeb
is a cloud native modular real time
database Etc so this is like almost
exactly to what I would say I think it's
still going um yeah so it's streaming
the response back as the Toons come in
it's just displaying them yes and it's
it right right now we have it so we need
to have the full response we're not like
doing it word by word um but that's
something that we want to improve this
is like the first iteration of it but we
are constantly um improving it if you
guys would like to contribute it's open
source and then another cool thing that
I like about this is you can use verba
on your own data um if I go to is it
sorry ask um is it just based on that is
it summarizing all the documents that
are pulled out that are relevant or is
it just the one that's highlighted right
there yeah um so it's mashing together
all of the like the most relevant
documents but this is the first source
so the distance from the query to the is
the um yeah and then you can like Bop
around and then you can also go to the
document where it actually is
referencing it which is quite neat um
yeah so for I have a question yesterday
I was trying to have a conversation with
another speaker and I didn't know the
match between my background and his
background so I asked D chat AI oh
interesting so I asked like this is this
is the professor CV and I want I have
this particular project on chess I'm
chess gu so how does this match why
should I do and he said oh that's the
perfect Professor he does ancient board
game stuff these are his papers I'm like
clicking it's not work it's clicking not
working I waited like 15 20 minutes
until because is I this is correct no so
just came up so uh I didn't get the part
I missed the part that these links are
real how does this check happened
because this Hallucination is still
happening big issue you cannot even ask
a proper question today I at work you
said don't tell your employer to use CHP
today I used and and I had a meeting and
I'm looking at the link and the link is
supposed to call some AWS or Google
Cloud website no it doesn't go there it
just it doesn't I'm like what what is
going on so I'm very skeptical about uh
this cation part I just want to
understand how this is not doing that
funny thing it actually does hallucinate
all LMS are going all language WS are
going to hallucinate um someone actually
asked a question in our community
Channel and it's was like is this right
is this code right it's not working and
we're like yes sorry it um outputed the
incorrect code and this is really
dependent on the like the rag techniques
that you use and like how you feed it
into the language model um it's like the
Llama index has done a lot of great work
and they have Advanced Techniques to
kind of like solve this issue but it
does hallucinate this is just they it
doesn't completely remove hallucination
but it just makes it context aware okay
that's that's good because you you said
you you know where where the reference
is sometimes the reference is not the
reference you seek it says this is just
not true it happened multiple
times so these are like documents that
you have in your in your data I guess
you're going show that yeah so verba is
using our document ation our blog post
and then eventually we will add YouTube
um Conor's uh YouTube podcast as um
transcripts so it can fetch his YouTube
videos and then we can have like P
conversations with the YouTube videos as
well and then also our Forum as another
source of information um it does
hallucinate it is using we documentation
um but if you scroll down here here are
the instructions I I apologize but I
just I just don't really know these
kinds of things so so what's happening
in the back
is you give it a prompt we finds the
most relevant documents and then is
passing that to chat gbt is like the
context and then it passes the actual
question and that's what it's showing up
yeah and then offit the response that's
why the huc can happen in the text
portion but the reference cannot be a
hallucination that's a good thing that's
that's very important that was a bug in
your case it was not supposed to do that
because I asked big chat and big chat
came up with fake references what
the link is correct it's just that the
description of
the referen
is so in this case you know the you know
the reference exactly because it was
actually pulled out of the database it
wasn't just created by
the say that as like metadata of we know
this if people want to learn more here's
that like you can use as a metadata from
the retrieval like this is the
information if you want to go like put
that at the end of the response exactly
it would be nice to also be able to
filter by the metadata so maybe you
don't want to reference the block post
because I don't know you just don't like
it you prer the documentation you can
maybe filter that out as an good
iteration I'll add that to Edward's
project this is sorry this is probably a
tangent but like if if it's passing open
I me I guess I'm still stuck on the if
passing all that information to the chbt
and then keeping all that context I
guess I was thinking that there Our uhal
Generation where it's passing
essentially the um the vector itself
like the representation of the document
not the like the text of the document
itself correct because it's retrieving
it from weate I mean weate stores the
object along with its embedding but it
would pass in the um
embedding reference to Chach not
necessarily like the whole document and
then it have to trunk again and go
through that like whole process but not
what it's doing now it's it's just
passing just the taex but there would be
a world in which you can implement it to
actually take the the embedding use the
embedding rather no that's what it's
doing it's passing in the embedding only
right
yeah yeah the problem is the embedding
models are usually different from the
Laten space of the language models so
like if I try to give you the vector
from the opening eyes 8 to2 end point to
chbt it's not in the same blatant space
I can't just put it in there but but
yeah the the famous paper about that is
deep mind's retro model where they're
trying to align it so the language model
and the embedding model are trained like
end to end like that and then by handing
it the vector instead of just the input
text you're able to like really blow up
the size of the Transformer memory this
way I see interesting
okay that's pretty Cutting
Edge
I guess I was I don't know I don't know
what I was like reading about but like I
guess I was understanding that there's a
way that you can take the
representations from the model itself
and store those as embeddings and pass
that as the as the input to the model
right and then they're align right the
same well crazy usually eding models are
like pretty small models because as a
you do like a billion inferences like
you know I remember one time we when
hiking face had had that bloom language
model they're like we're going to encode
it with it and it's like it's going to
take you forever cuz you're doing like a
billion pred like you know how much you
pay for your chat gbt if you to do a
billion of
those yeah okay yeah that makes
sense always be careful when a software
has your credit
card which is another thing to note with
for but is you do have to connect it to
open a I mean with us hosting it it is
free to use um but if you want to use it
on your custom data and import own data
then you obviously have to pass in your
own key um so that's verba um I guess
another quick thing then I can is it
just with open AI then with open II you
can't use currently yes but we do want
to add Hy and face Transformers as well
so it's free to use and you don't have
to add your credit card which I know
some people are like a bit skeptical you
can post internal
yes is there anything with like llama oh
yeah that's another one as well yeah
kind of want to support for all the
models because especially with your
application I think like there are some
preferences I have another use case like
I write grants right so and the token
size is usually the grant instruction
are sometimes very large and they they
are out of scope to memory so it
forgets how this could how can this be
used for such use case I have a PDF say
like I have a PDF with a lot of
instruction that I will summarize to the
bare minimum of the what the grant is
about and I want to start right the ask
questions to the to the llm and get
answers yeah um so I can share about
that but that is definitely doable with
these different and I just wanted to
share that it does output code so if you
go home and you're like I want to go
through the weate documentation but I
have a question you can ask no Community
slack can ask going her form but then
maybe Vera has the
answer she quite handy um so yes uh
these are the we8 recipes um that I'm
very proud of but um here we have
generative search which is doing that
retrieval augmented generation so it's
creating those answers then we have
hybrid search and then we also have
similarity search or text which is pure
Vector search um but then we have
various
Integrations as well and I think what
you would be most interested in is if
you go have you used L index
before
index it's an llm framework um so they
handle like the the trunking the like
orchestration
of getting you that answer from your PDF
um yeah I guess that's the best
way the similarity surve database that's
your functionality yes so yeah you
definitely still need they call it a
vector store and we is a part of it um
and that's just important for you know
like the database side of it um they do
have great query engines as well um so
it's like a little bit more more it is
more advanced than like the vector
search the hybrid search um but if you
want to do pure Vector search which is
sometimes enough then you can just use
we
solely um okay one
example I can't remember which one it is
so I am sorry um but basically llama
index has llama Hub and this is where
they have a whole bunch of different uh
data loaders so you have like PDFs
Powerpoints and you can use unstructured
which is great so like this one I'm in
all of the data that is hosted on this
URL you can chat with this document um
okay
sorry this one does not have PDFs but
essentially we just use Link okay many
many PDFs are also exist on the web in
the grand website so it's yeah HT H
https think so yeah um yeah you can pass
in URLs PowerPoints documents all of
that ja so what's a bit confusing to me
is that there's a bunch of projects like
Lama index um other similar ones and
they have overlapping functionality and
sometimes they sit on top of each other
like you use we on top of Lama index but
you could use l chain on top of this and
that and sometimes hard to figure out
which one should you pick what's what's
the best choice depending on what you do
I don't think I'm allowed to give
that but essentially yeah llama index
and light chain they are doing the same
thing it's a great market right now so
everyone wants like a piece of the pie
um right now I'm making tutorials on
llma index so I'm going to be more
biased but L chain is also doing great
things as well so should I think of Lama
index as an ingestion tool like the
parsing piece the chunking piece that's
what it's for yeah so you can extract
the data so from the PDFs the websites
then they also handle the chunking so
they have like they call it nodes so
taking your PDF document and making it
into smaller trunks and then it's going
to vectorize that store in your vector
database by using this Vector store and
then you create this query
engine and um yeah I won't share it that
some PDFs are really long so it's just
not
possible when you write the grant
they're like 50 page Grant and then
there's questions related to this PDF
you have to search PDF different
location and you expect answer from that
location it's difficult it comes
difficult to answer every question by
one one by one and llama index also so
has different indexes as well so they
have like the um they have a hierarchal
kind of index where it stores like the
top node will be the full document but
then each node or each trunk is like
related to each and this is great for
like summarization because what if you
want like one page summarize that and
then you need to properly store it and
then that would probably make
it the summarization in this case I mean
it could yes with the query engine that
you use would depend um they have like
various qu engines they also have like
if you ask a very complex question that
I think in data science field is called
multihop um it'll break down like what
is refc and we8 it needs to understand
what refc is and then also what is weate
and then it comes together and combines
the um responses to make one simple
response that is coherent us response
synthesizer which is like a whole other
thing that you can also configure for
your
application and we as the vector store
in this sort of model that you're
describing okay but then if uh just
Vector search and like generative search
is enough for you then you don't
necessarily need to use l index it's
like this fancy like query engine and
all of
this questions also like to train to
actually do
the the
embedding it doesn't we do handle that
we handle itation you just pass in your
open AI key and then we'll pass it on on
to open Ai and then open a return those
embeddings and we'll store it in weey in
your vector class oh
okay and then you can also has you need
you need that but it doesn't have to be
open AI it could be whatever we have coh
here we have hi face
got okay so that was a bit about the
demo I didn't go in order so yeah that
was my talk I hope
I'm thank you
[Applause]
can I ask it's at the end now maybe it's
a bit more time so your database is a
graph database um and L can part as
these documents and create a graph of
the chunks maybe the way they're related
so how do you take advantage of the
graph structure in your database um
because that's something that you have
another other sity search database don't
don't have
actually answer well I guess with the
with the graph structure there's like
for one you know we were talking ear
about recommendation systems and like
one thing we do is you'd have like user
is one class and class is like
collections or tables like that's our
abstraction for like you know table and
so be like user liked product and so we
would average the three say you like
three products and we'd average those
three vectors represent the user to then
search at the user and that that's a
pretty good way to get like a really
easy recommendation that's mostly what
we use the graph for one idea is um you
search in one index and this this index
links to another index which is you know
a bit confusing but it' be like if you
have like a you have like a structured
table within a Wikipedia page so you're
like billionaires on Wikipedia and then
there's like a table and then you want
to do like an SQL style query CU we also
do have like most of the it's not like
the super Advanced SQL style indexing
but if you want to just take like the
average age of billionaires you could do
that also M so you can like link indexes
that way but um mostly with the graph
structure um you know like we we can do
just like filtered Vector search like
the blog like if you want to search blog
posts or documentation and I would
probably advise that before I'd start
separating the classes because also the
the biggest benefit of the technology is
like scaling the approximate nearest
neighbor so I don't really recommend
splitting it into multiple tables okay I
see very cool other other questions we
still have a few minutes of
Link well technically we have all the
time in the
world
shair this is the website and this is
where we have the documentation so we're
at P data so I'm assuming everyone
prefers
python um so this is the installation
and setup um so essentially the steps
are to connect your weate instance
Define your schema so how should the
data be stored so you have your class
and then you have your properties that
metadata you upload it to your web
instance and then boom you're searching
um I guess in the Rees I can share how
how like this is a kind of a weird
question not a well formulated question
how how small is this could you just
have this on like a bunch of little
like could could a person have their own
little like instance like running in you
know some small
container yeah like yeah separated out
or something like that create a Docker
container and you just map to a sub
folder on your U laptop or something and
then you can just run it for like I
guess yeah I guess I guess is it small
enough to be able to like do that like
feasibly like is it that's the I haven't
run into any problems but then again my
data hasn't like
exceeded like 10,000
some
um here's a h that's a really
interesting thought because you know
like I do I do scientific research so I
have like a whole bunch of papers that
I've
never this like very useful way to find
those documents if you can you know do
the correct Factor space but a trick
would be maybe the documents have
some some like tables or figures or
things and only the text portion
might go well through this they just or
was it Google or Facebook just published
n which is specifically for specifically
for extracting information from
scientific articles really so that's
this that's like another reason this was
like top of mind okay what's the name of
that maybe n nou n g
a that's right it's been it's been
trending on gith it's yeah like multi
it's the images and stuff multimodel I I
haven't been able to play with it okay
that's sorry I can also share
um thanks about we use your
laptop
else um because I I didn't set up the
the
Wi-Fi um so under web tutorials I have
this how to address PDFs using
unstructured doio um which we've
partnered with in the past and actually
The Notebook is using to research
papers um because unstructured has like
uses the latest OCR models and like has
different ways of indexing or like
parsing through the PDF documents that
handle tables specifically in images um
so here is Connor's
paper
involved um so how unstructured does it
I mean I'm not super familiar with
instructure but for the scemo purpose um
what it's doing is it's creating an
element from it
and then it will partition it so you can
see that it's taking out the abstract
the intro the background every
subheading that is in the research paper
um doing some other stuff whatever it
doesn't matter but essentially at the
end and then this is where you are
connecting to your we instance um so we
embedded is one way to run it where just
run in your application but once you
close out of it you'll have to do
everything all over again so just keep
that in mind defining the schema so I
have my class document which is that one
research paper and then the source is
the text and then also some reason we
restoring the abstract as well
separately okay moving on to the end is
just where we ask questions and I think
this this was an older example but you
can see that we are running a
bm25 uh query and I'm curious about
papers about house prices um so it's
able to extract the document that is
talking about this and really it as
paper two but again it could output the
title to be a bit more specific and then
you could reference it um as like your
Source um and then here we have the
generative module um so this is the
prompt I'm asking it to summarize the
paper and the abstract is it's taking
the abstract from the paper that it's
retrieving and then generating a summary
so this is exactly what you're looking
for um and yeah so just get like a quick
summary about the first paper and then
the second paper as well and then there
were a few limitations that we ran into
but I'm unstructured raised a lot of
money recently so they're just getting
better one way to do that unstructed is
that free is that yes it is
free and then if you just want to use
llama index there's the Llama
hub
so unstructured
has there we go unstructured is here so
see you can pass in text documents
documents PowerPoints jpeg all
that so Lama index is on top of
unstructured they don't do the wrong
paring no so unstructured was added to
llama index okay because and even we is
on here so if you already have your VV
instance running and you don't want to
go through the process of factorizing
and destroying it in the index
um you can use the weate
loader and that is an option to just
connect llama index to your existing we
intins so and then I have that in the
recipes as well um just to get people a
few
options yeah do
that
cool exciting
times thank you so much yeah thank you
than you
yeah